avec nous ce soir notre invité est jean
bédard qui est le pdg de la cage et du
groupe sportscene que nous invitons pour
parler de l'avenir de son entreprise
bonsoir monsieur bédard bonsoir mais
d'abord on va parler un peu de la
situation monsieur bédard comment se
porte votre entreprise parce que vous
êtes de nouveau obligé dans le cas de la
cage comme dans le cas de tous les
restaurants au québec d'être fermés en
quelques surtout fait la livraison mais
les salles à manger sont fermés comment
va l'entreprise
voudrait qu'un nouveau financier c'est
pas de certaines préoccupations les
programmes sont en place ont bien
fonctionné lors des trois premiers
confirmant ce qui est très très
difficile en ce moment c'est beaucoup
plus pour nos employés d'avoir une
nouvelle comme ça alors que nous on
apprenait beaucoup bon les mesures
sanitaires travailler avec des masses
fait attention on est trop de passes pas
vaccinale on s'attendait vraiment pas à
peu près comme tout le monde d'avoir
fermeture encore une fois à la fin
décembre comme ça à la fin de l'année je
pense et ce qui est plus dur en ce
moment pour le moral de s'assurer de
garder nos jeunes d'avoir un message
d'espoir pour leur dire que finalement
vous falloir qu'on apprenne à vivre avec
ce virus là et on souhaite la mort dit
nouvelle positive pour l'industrie le
très prochainement mais est-ce que ça
remet en question vos plans votre plan
stratégique qui est en cours j'userai se
reporte de quelques mois je dirais que
le signe que j'ai donné mon équipe nous
on avait planifié d'ouvrir trois
nouveaux restaurants au mois de février
on va les ouvrez quand même quitte à ce
que ça soit hanté calme moi je suis
convaincu qu'il faut apprendre à vivre
maintenant avec ce virus là par la
vaccination par le passeport vaccinale
les gens ont tous été pris par surprise
le système de santé n'était pas prêt à
recevoir ce nombre de patients le trop
grand mais moi je dis à mes équipes
préparez-vous on continue on est
reportée d'un mois ou deux ça remet pas
en cause du tout notre plan ça veut dire
quoi vivre avec le virus pour vous en
faites avec les mesures avec les liens
les nouvelles normes sanitaires faire
attention le masque d'être plus
longtemps gérer un nouvel élément qui
est le passeport vaccinale c'est ça je
pense qu'il va falloir que l'industrie
ça me tue enfin l'attention avec ses
employés la sécurité des consommateurs
également mais je regarde ce qui se
passe à l'extérieur je pense que pays
qui ont décidé de continuer de vivre
puis c'est ce que je souhaite qu'ils
arrivent au québec le très prochainement
et avec vous vous êtes beaucoup exprimé
depuis le début de la pandémie où vous
vous êtes un leader dans le monde de la
restauration comme citoyen comme
entrepreneur quand vous entendez parler
de cette taxe santé de cette
contribution santé c'est quoi votre
réflexion là dessus
moi je dirais que je suis plus de
l'école positive c'est-à-dire de
de remercier ceux qui prennent le temps
se faire vacciner ceux qui ont leurs
passeports vaccinale de leur donner
accès évidemment des restaurants comme
ça
je suis pas vraiment d'opinion par
rapport aux freins je pense que comme
comme citoyen on doit travailler
ensemble pour pour apprendre à vivre
avec ce virus lol parce qu'on va avoir
encore un bout de terre viva verso moi
je suis beaucoup de l' approche positive
plutôt que de la proche coercitives
privatisation de votre entreprise et
officielle aujourd'hui les actionnaires
ont approuvé à plus de 99 % l'ailé les
voir avec vos partenaires vous rachetez
donc l'entreprise qui sort de la bourse
opération de plus de 50 millions de
dollars pourquoi vous faites ça et
pourquoi vous le fait maintenant
ben en fait de plus en plus complexes à
avoir une compagnie publique on le sait
le depuis les mois à bourse c'est très
complexe la gouvernance était de plus en
plus exigeante avec tout ce qui s'est
passé les scandales que eu les gestes de
plus en plus prudents et nous on se
remet pas de ce levier la com com
entreprise on avait à peu près juste les
inconvénients et moins les avantages
donc en pandémie en plus en plus de
gérer cette pandémie loge à rennes aux
employés ben on avait également toute
cette fardeau supplémentaire donc c'est
là qu'on a appris la décision que pour
le bien à long terme de l'entreprise que
c'était peut-être une bonne un bon temps
pour privatiser la société je pense que
l'or qui était fait nos actionnaires et
très bonne je pense qu'ils nous ont
supportés depuis plusieurs années ça va
nous permettre vraiment nous concentrer
à 100% premièrement à finir
mais là on sait pas quand est-ce que ça
va finir parce qu'à chaque fois qu'on a
on avait vraiment l'impression que c'est
qu'on a qu'on s'en sortait et le paf ce
variant hyper vie d'autres variantes
vous dites il faut apprendre à vivre
avec la cage aux sports la cage s'est
tournée vraiment vers la livraison les
boîtes de prêts à cuisiner est-ce que
vous continuez à chercher à innover
je dirais que le grand changement que
c'était en fait qui est allumée pendant
cette crise là c'est surtout si notre
performance au détail dans les épiceries
notre notre ligne d'affaires
exploser pendant cette période je pense
que à long terme comme je dis tout le
temps on ait pu n'être nécessairement
dans la restauration des rendus dans
l'alimentation donc on nourrit les gens
sur place on les nourrit également là en
livraison en t4 mais également à
l'épicerie de chance et de la façon je
pense pour devront aborder l'avenir
la gestion qui vous redonne qui s'est
dit oh oui à faire en fait on le voyait
venez dans notre plan stratégique et on
avait déposé notre la stratégie que 11
mars la journée qu'on a fermé neuf
salles à manger c'était intégral dans
notre plan stratégique ce que la
pandémie a fait c'est que l'accélérer ce
comportement du consommateur l'eau
heureusement on s'était préparé à ça ça
nous a permis de passer quand même ces
deux dernières années là de façon
différée spectable et lobait ce qu'on
souhaite c'est qu'on soit capable de
mettre en place une fois pour toutes
plus on regarde on regarde en avant ok
merci bonne chance et bonne année à vous
aussi merci merci merci beaucoup au
revoir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh